the most high-profile tourists of the
day arrived on the outskirts of cairo to
take in a true wonder of the world
the great pyramid the largest in egypt
and oldest in giza prince charles has
been here before but this was the first
time for camilla on the third day of
their middle east tour
as the sun set the couple their
entourage and the media made their way
to see the magnificent sphinx
posing for the cameras again this the
image that egypt wants us to see
these are of course the pictures that
will always sell so well from any royal
tour but what is most important is that
significant diplomatic work that's going
on behind the scenes and when you drive
around cairo you can see exactly why
the royal couple would have seen all of
this the poverty pollution and crowded
streets even through the tight security
as they made their way to meet
controversial president cece who came to
power in a military coup eight years ago
but still faces serious questions about
his human rights record
something campaigners hoped the prince
was brave enough to raise we would hope
so uh is that the prince would raise uh
important human rights
conditions and violations with uh with
president sisi uh we would want to make
that this is this visit would not just
be used for propaganda purposes
of course both sides would want these
public displays of friendship especially
with egypt following the uk and hosting
the next climate conference cop 27.
the prince praising their ancestors who
created the pyramids the fact that they
could do this reminds us how profoundly
they understood the sacred geometry of
nature
the fact that they
did so
in fact they did do this reminds us
that they understood this this knowledge
was essential to life and death
a rallying message to his hosts and a
global audience with these pictures
destined to be sent around the world
rhiannon mills sky news inc cairo